our weekly covid check-in we tend to do
this tuesday or wednesday each week a
very welcome update is that cases and
deaths globally and in the united states
continue declining let's start with u.s
cases u.s cases are now down
just more than 53 percent from their
delta wave peak the delta wave peak was
about 163 000 cases a day
um being down more than 50 percent is a
great sign and we're coming down at
roughly the same rate as we've been
seeing for a few weeks if this decline
continues four more weeks we will be in
nice shape by thanksgiving
second no guarantee that will happen by
the way second deaths in the united
states those tend to lag cases by three
to four weeks deaths continue coming
down
from their delta peak of just shy of 2
000 deaths a day we're now down about 33
percent now that's still a crazy amount
of death every day
1350 people
in the u.s every day dying of covid
that's roughly 13 times that of the flu
on an annualized basis that's close to
half a 9 11 a day
but going down and not up at this time
is welcome
globally we're still seeing cases
decline globally cases are now down
about 40 from their delta peak
the delta peak the global delta peak
these are bonkers numbers we were seeing
660 000 cases a day
we're now seeing about 400 000 cases a
day a crazy number but significantly
lower and then globally covet deaths
also declining we did see 10 000 daily
deaths from covet at the peak of the
delta wave that's down about 37 percent
but that still means 6 400 people every
day are dying from covid now how about
vaccination
in the u.s we've really seen a sort of
leveling off of vaccination
we're at roughly 850 000 doses per day
at one point you might remember and you
see it on this chart we saw daily us
vaccinations go all the way down to
about half a million a day that was
mid-july
then then they came up to about a
million a day and then declined and then
back up to a million a day and now about
850 000 a day now that's not great these
are not inspiring numbers and the other
thing to consider is with more and more
people getting third doses you have to
understand that this number of daily
doses
corresponds to fewer newly vaccinated
people
because not only before we had to say
okay if there's a million doses
and about 10 percent of people don't go
for their second dose every million
doses probably means 600 000 people
getting their their first dose
now with people getting third doses i
don't know what the numbers are but you
would imagine for every million doses it
might only be
you know 400 000 people getting their
their first dose so that's not great
around the world sadly daily
vaccinations also experiencing a
significant decline at one point we were
seeing 40 million daily vaccinations i
told you last week we were seeing about
25 million
we're now seeing about 20 million doses
a day globally
we've got 7.8 billion people on the
planet that's not great
we do need to get more doses to
countries that have not yet really
gotten access and try to scale those
numbers up i've talked about you know 78
million doses a day would be great where
do i get that well 7.8 billion people on
the planet if you can do 78 million
doses a day you're giving a dose to one
percent of the global population a day
that would be a great number we're at
less than a third of that right now few
other bits of news the nhl has suspended
um evander kane for submitting a forged
fake
fraudulent fugazi vaccination card we'll
be discussing that on today's bonus show
the uk has one of the highest covet
infection rates in the world why
we will be talking about that on today's
bonus show and uh yes there is a miami
private school
which is making all sorts of bogus
claims about vaccines
and they are saying if you get a vaccine
you've got to stay home for 30 days
that won't be on today's bonus show but
on a bonus show upcoming wild wild stuff
going on down there in miami make sure
you're following me on twitter
at d pacman we're gonna take a quick
break and be back this is a this is a
meaty show today very very meaty show